just before we get started some of you
might know that i have another channel
called megaprojects which is all about
megaprojects i've mentioned it here
before
if you don't subscribe to that channel
well please do but by popular demand i
wanted to cover things that weren't
quite
mega enough for that channel so i
started a new channel it's called
side project you can see what we did
there it covers secret soviet space
weapons world war ii's greatest airplane
some of
history's lost treasures and the
movement of london bridge
from london to a random town in america
stuff
like that new videos three times a week
on that channel so if you're thinking oh
simon doesn't make enough videos for me
well don't worry
head on over to side projects and
subscribe there is a link below and
let's get started
who was arkanartan for 3 300 years this
question
would have yielded only puzzled
expressions as
his deeds were considered so vile and
outrageous that the man who was once
pharaoh of egypt
was condemned to damnatio memories a
process where others try to eliminate
all mentions of him from history and
make it look like he never
existed for thousands of years this was
the case
it wasn't until the late 19th and early
20th centuries when
modern archaeologists excavated the lost
city of amana
and we were able to rediscover the reign
of akhenaten
so what did he do that was so heinous
well he was arguably ancient egypt's
greatest heretic
akhenaten abandoned the traditional gods
who had been worshipped for thousands of
years
and instead instituted a new religion
called artemism which was centered
around the worship of arton the sundisk
he also moved the capital of egypt from
thebes to a new city that he built
called ammana
also called arkhanaten during his reign
for this reason the time span that
covers his reign as well as those that
immediately followed is also referred to
as the amana period the extent to which
arcanatan suppressed the old forms of
religious expression is still a matter
of debate among scholars but
the people of ancient egypt were
definitely not happy with him almost
immediately after he died they
got to work restoring the old ways and
the pharaohs who
followed distanced themselves from his
beliefs nowadays we're much more
familiar with his son tutankhamen who
realistically
didn't actually do anything of note in
his lifetime
but today we seek to rectify this a bit
by taking a look at arkhanat and the
heretical pharaoh who launched a
religious revolution
akhenaten was born sometime in the first
half of the 14th century bc most likely
during the 1370s
he was part of egypt's 18th dynasty the
first one
of the new kingdom which arguably saw
the egyptian empire
reach the peak of its power most of the
pharaohs we've covered so far like
tutankhamen hat sheppswood and
mosey iii have all been part of the same
dynasty so it's pretty fair to say that
this was a crucial part in the history
of egypt
akhenaten's father was pharaoh amenhotep
iii also known as ammon hotep the
magnificent he is generally considered
one of ancient egypt's greatest rulers
presiding over a lengthy reign of almost
40 years marked by prosperity peace and
stability
akhenaten's mother was ty the pharaoh's
great royal wife
he was actually the second son that the
two had together and was not originally
planned to take over the throne
however his older brother crown prince
that moses died of an unknown cause
sometime during the second half of their
father's reign and therefore akhenaten
became the next in line he was not
called akanatan at the time of course
this name was
roughly translated to one who is
serviceable to arton
and he only adopted it as pharaoh once
he instituted his new religious policies
up until that point he was arman hoteb
iv but
will stick to akhenaten to avoid a lot
of confusion with his father
we cannot tell you almost anything about
his early life some egyptologists
speculate that he may have served as a
high priest before taking the throne
because his brother had done the same
while he was still the successor and
maybe this is where he first developed
his strong devotion
to the arten also spelled aten this
deity
actually predated akhenaten by a long
way its first mentions date back to the
old kingdom although back then
it seemed to be simply a word used to
refer to the sun disk itself and
it wasn't an actual deity but rather an
element
of the sun god by the middle kingdom
though there were already references to
arton as a creator so at some point
centuries before
akhenaten came along arten had already
morphed into
a sort of solar deity another hotly
debated aspect to backnatan's life is
when exactly he took over the throne
there are some scholars who assert that
amenhotep iii made his son co-regent
while he was still
pharaoh many others argue strongly
against this view and even the length of
the co-regency
is heavily disputed for our purposes
we're going to assume that akhenaten
became the new pharaoh of egypt after
the death of his father
this happened around 1353 bc pharaoh
almanhotep iii
died in his late 40s or early 50s in his
38th or 39th regular year and he was
buried in the valley of the kings
his son followed him to the throne still
under the name amenhotep iv it was
around this time that he married his
great royal wife
nefertiti
the first years of akhenaten's reign
were traditional for
lack of a better word where he followed
the regular customs of the time and
mainly continued policies and practices
that had been
set out by his father he expressed his
worship of the art and but not
in an other way this wasn't considered
unusual because armanhotep iii
also emphasized the worship of the arten
as a call back to their
ancestors between the middle kingdom and
new kingdom there was a span of time
dubbed the second intermediate period it
was considered a dark time for egypt as
parts of the land were
not ruled by native egyptians but rather
by hicksos a
group of people from the levant who
arrived in the area and took over in the
17th century bc
eventually the xos were defeated and
driven away permanently by omose the
first who founded the 18th dynasty the
one that we're in right now
the point is that after the xos were
gone the pharaohs who followed were
eager to get
back to their roots they wanted to do
away with the traditions and culture of
the hicks arse and
bring back many customs and religious
practices from their forefathers from
the middle kingdom and beyond and well
that is how the arton
entered the egyptian public
consciousness once more
armenhotep iii might have worshipped
arten but he never neglected
ammun who by that point had become one
of the most important gods in the
egyptian pantheon and
the patron deity of thebes in fact
ahman's significance during the 18th
dynasty grew
so much that he began being identified
alongside
ra the sun god as a single entity named
ahman rah
the first indication that akhenaten had
plans of his own came a few years into
his reign when he scheduled a said
festival for himself
this was one of egypt's oldest
traditions it was a sort of
jubilee with a grand feast meant to
celebrate the original unification
between
upper and lower egypt traditionally a
pharaoh organized his first set festival
once he reigned for 30 years and
in three year increments from then on
akhenaten did it
after only two or three years the reason
for this has been widely speculated some
scholars think he was
mentally preparing himself for the more
drastic steps he was about to take
others believe akhenaten wanted to
symbolically link his reign
to that of his father so he organized a
said festival just three years after the
previous one
of ahman hotep iii and some concluded
that the pharaoh simply saw it as a
convenient excuse for him to build loads
of new monuments and temples dedicated
to the art and without
anyone raising an eyebrow indeed the
greatest one of all was a temple complex
constructed right outside
karnak named gempatan or arton is found
which went against egyptian building
conventions by having no roof so that
the sunlight
could freely enter the complex by the
fifth year of his reign the pharaoh
decided it was time for a true
revolution he changed his role territory
officially adopting the name
akhenaten and instituting the worship of
the arton throughout his kingdom
he expressed his devotion to the sun
disc in several hymns and poems
the most famous of which is the great
hymn to the arten a composition of
thirteen stanzas which was found
inscribed on several rock tombs
unsurprisingly many egyptians were
outraged by akhenaten particularly the
priests who were about to lose the
majority of their power
influence and wealth however the pharaoh
was not an idiot and he knew that he
would not be able to pull off his
religious reform
without support from anyone and he got
that support from the army
the kingdom was coming off from a period
of prosperity so the soldiers were
already pretty content but
akhenaten still made sure to praise and
celebrate them
whenever the opportunity arose as well
as maintain good relations with his
military leaders
clearly this worked as there were no
major uprisings during his reign and the
disavowal of the cult of arten
only took place after his death because
of his actions akhenaten has been
heralded by some modern scholars the
first monotheist in history meaning the
first person to express belief in a
single god
others reject this label and qualify his
reign more as
a henotheistic period of egypt meaning
that while worship was focused on a
single deity he didn't necessarily
reject the possible existence of others
either way akhenaten wanted nothing to
do with the old gods of egypt anymore
and he felt that his worship of the
arton
needed to be concentrated in a virgin
site one that was free from the touch
and influence of
the former pantheon
as shocking as akhenaten's abandonment
of the old gods was
so was his decision to leave sebes the
city that had functioned as egypt's
capital for the greater part of its
history up until then but the pharaoh
wanted to found a new capital
in pristine land he chose an uninhabited
site on the eastern bank of the nile and
took around twenty thousand people with
him to his new settlement he called it
acantharton or horizon of the atom
but it is better known by its later name
amana
obviously building a new city from
scratch in a short period of time
was a huge undertaking and there is grim
evidence to
suggest that the people in omana were
worked to the bone once the largest
cemetery in amana was excavated modern
archaeologists found the remains
of 432 people of the ones whose age was
established 70
died before the age of 35 while only 9
people lived past 50.
not only that but the children had their
growth stunted due to malnutrition while
many adults had spinal damage from being
overworked
an even darker picture is painted by
another cemetery this time
located near the royal limestone quarry
a whopping 92 percent of the individuals
buried there were under 25 years old
while
half of them were under 15. amana might
have been the ideal city in the mind of
arkhanaten but all indications seem to
suggest that he only cared about himself
and his god while
the people of omana lived in miserable
conditions and were being worked to
death
in order to cope with the construction
demands of the pharaoh builders created
a new type of stone block
called toilet hats made out of limestone
they were much smaller than the blocks
used in egyptian construction but they
were also cut to a standard size which
was
not typically done before theoretically
this made them more efficient but
they still did not catch on and the
usage of talent had ended shortly after
the amana period
it probably would not surprise you to
learn that the main structures in amana
were the royal palaces for akhenaten
and temples for the artem the main place
of worship was the great temple of the
arton in the center of the city while
a secondary small art and temple was
located near to the royal palaces like
all other art and temples they had
two features that distinguished them
from traditional egyptian places of
worship they were open air with no roof
and
they also did not feature any cult
images of the arten which was
in fact a recurring theme in artemisiam
while the other gods were commonly
depicted as having human bodies in human
or animal heads zachenarton insisted
that
the arten was everywhere in every one
and thus transcended the need for any
kind
of physical form therefore the artem was
always depicted as only a disk
emitting solar rays something else that
came out of ammana was
a new art style dubbed simply the amana
art style again
it did not last longer than akhenaten's
reign but some works have survived and
they create a pretty stark contrast to
the traditional
ancient egyptian art the most striking
differences concern the ways humans were
depicted in the amana style they were
taller and more slender the facial
features were elongated in the chest
hands and legs with sin while the
stomach and thighs were often bloated
the same skin color was
used for men and women and achenaten
himself was depicted with feminine
features
some egyptologists believed that this
was actually a more realistic view of
what the pharaoh
really looked like because he might have
suffered from one or more genetic
disorders like marfan syndrome which
caused elongated extremities or
kleinfelder syndrome which led to male
breast enlargement
it is speculated that other pharaohs
from the 18th dynasty also suffered from
these ailments but
this is yet to be proven conclusively
akhenaten ruled egypt for approximately
17 years and his reign was clearly
dominated by his devotion to the arten
which became
increasingly fanatical as the years went
by not satisfied with simply building a
new capital dedicated to his god
he later had older temples dismantled
and their priests killed as
he ordered the names of the old gods be
chiseled out of all cravings from
giant stellai to small tablets we don't
actually have a lot of detailed
information about what happened in egypt
during the reign of akhenaten
because of the whole damnatio memorizing
and having all mentions of him destroyed
but we do know
a lot more about his international
relations thanks to a treasure trove of
information that somehow survived
known as the amana letters this consists
of over 380 tablets written in the
acadian language using cuneiform that
mostly represent diplomatic
correspondence from neighboring city
administrators and
kings to the pharaoh the tone used in
the tablets changes depending on who the
sender was some of them
came from vassals of egypt so naturally
the tone was very deferential addressing
akhenaten as
the son my lord while referring to
themselves as his servants
others while still cordial came from
rulers of similar rank like the kings of
mattani or babylon and the tone
reflected their equal status
regardless of the way they were written
many letters had similar content
they expressed displeasure
disappointment concern and
uneasiness at akhenaten for neglecting
some of his international duties
some of these were specific for example
the king of metani
tushrata complains in one tablet that
akhenaten seemingly reneged on a deal
made by his father
to give the king solid gold statues as
dowry for a princess bride from matani
it would seem that akhenaten sent to
shirata gold-plated statues instead
many letters concerned the most pressing
issue in the region at that time the
rise of a dangerous foe
the hittites and they showed how little
akhenaten cared about
matters that had nothing to do with the
arten it was in fact during akhenaten's
reign that the hittites reached the
peak of their power and by the time
tutankhamun came to the throne the
hittite empire was just as strong as
egypt
first the mittani asked akhenaten for
assistance in
their war with the hittites but there
was no help forthcoming
in fact egypt hoped to curry favor with
the new regional power and withdrew
all support to matani allowing the king
there to
assassinate tasharata and sack his
capital of
washikani of course this only served to
show the rest of the world that egypt
was
weak and vulnerable so the hittites
pressed the attack and
went into syria where there were
city-states and kingdoms that were
vassals of egypt and
theoretically under its protection the
city-states that weren't conquered were
angered by egypt's inaction and they
rebelled prompting akhenaten to lose the
territory he used trap dominion over in
syria as far as we can tell
he never attempted to get it back
[Music]
the last years of akhenaten's reign are
one big question mark
the most confusing and controversial
aspect was his succession and the couple
of years in between the reigns of
akhenaten and his son tutankhamen the
problem is
that we know there were two other
pharaohs with very short reigns between
father and son
smekinare and neferno ferreten however
that is pretty much all we know who they
were
how they were connected to akhenaten why
they became pharaohs
are all still mysteries that spur
debates among egyptologists
we're not sure if smenkocarre was male
or female but some evidence may suggest
that he served as co-region during the
last years of akhenaten's life
some believe that the same can be said
for neferna ferreten who was a woman
and may have been one of the pharaoh's
daughters or more likely the
new name of nefertiti once she became
pharaoh in her own right
akhenaten died circa 1336 bc of unknown
causes
afterwards menkhikare and neferneferatan
either ruled together as co-regents or
one
the other or both of them had individual
reigns as pharaoh we simply cannot say
with any certainty and it wasn't until
toontankman took the throne circus 1334
bc
that the historical record became
clearer this is because king tut was
still
a young boy when he became pharaoh and
his advisors made most of the decisions
for him
they realized that the cult of the art
and had no chance of surviving without
akhenaten so
they steadily made changes to revert
back to the old ways
and the old gods and shun everything
done by the former pharaoh
this included a mana itself as the city
was abandoned when the capital was
reverted back to thebes
it was still standing though it wasn't
actually destroyed until later when a
pharaoh called haramheb
came to power he was more thorough when
it came to wiping out the ammanna period
from history so he had the temples and
monuments built by akhenaten
dismantled and then recycled for new
structures that's why there were talent
hats from amana that were used as filler
material for
the pillars of luxor as far as akhenaten
was concerned his wish
you won't be surprised to find out was
to be buried in a mana he had a royal
tomb built for himself in the local
necropolis called the royal wadi and
extra chambers for nefertiti and one of
his daughters who died young maybe even
during childbirth he said
let a tomb be made for me in the eastern
mountain of akhenaten
and let my burial be made in it in the
millions of jubilees which the arton my
father decreed for me
led the burial of the king's chief wife
nefertiti be made in the millions of
years which my father decreed for her
let also the burial of the king's
daughter be made in it
he probably won't be surprised to learn
that his wish was ignored akhenaten was
buried in his tomb initially but was
later moved to the valley of the kings
and his royal tomb was desecrated
where exactly he ended up is again a
matter of some dispute most suggest his
final resting place was kv-55 a
small undecorated single chamber tomb
which only contained a single adult
mummy
placed in a sarcophagus whose facial
features had been destroyed
as were all names and personal
identifiers the identity of the mummy is
a controversial topic made even more
confusing by
the fact that it was originally
discerned to be a woman the body was in
fact male although the coffin itself was
designed for a woman many believe this
is akhenaten although
others have posited that the mummy may
belong to the obscure smenkukari
modern dna tests indicated that the
mummy was related to tutankhamen but
other scholars criticized them saying
that the dna was too degraded and the
mummies handled by so many people over
time that the results would be
inaccurate
this is another contentious point for
the time being but is somehow fitting
given
all the other aspects of akhenaten's
reign as
he is seemingly destined to go down in
history as
arguably the most controversial pharaoh
in the history of egypt
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also please do check out
that other channel i mentioned called
side projects which is
linked to below and thank you for
[Music]
watching